CTM Enfocus is the original reporting
you'll see only on CBS this morning
exposing new information on issues that
impact all of us today we are focusing
on the challenges facing child
protective services workers
five-year-old age a friend was found
dead in Illinois in April and his
parents were charged with murder
afterward we started looking into how
something like this could allegedly
happen despite previous interventions by
police and child welfare workers we
discovered hundreds of American children
known to CPS agencies died of
maltreatment every year CTM national
correspondent Jericka Duncan set out to
learn why Rikka what did you find out
you know this is why we do what we do as
journalists to really delve into
important issues we spent a day with a
Child Protective Services caseworker and
out of gammy County Wisconsin what we
witnessed was disturbing heartbreaking
and real for the protection of the
children we agreed to hide the parents
identities this is a story about the
challenges facing the men and women
tasked with ensuring the safety of
children across this country my biggest
concern this woman is pregnant with her
fifth child and admits using
methamphetamines as recently as two
weeks ago it's Brittany ploughman's job
to determine whether the kids living
here are in danger I have some packets
of information one for each child as a
caseworker for the Children Youth &
Families division in Outagamie County
Wisconsin plumbin has already helped by
putting two of the kids in daycare where
one just took her first steps she walked
and I didn't get to be there it's
difficult that you got so this is a
typical day for you that was pretty
heavy claman handles new cases typically
working with about 15 families at once
she's one of 28 social workers in a
County of more than 180,000 people their
thing
that you just you can't fathom you know
when a day-to-day basis you can't fathom
that a parent would do this to their
child I pushed him into the wall her
goal is to keep families together but
she's had two separate about a dozen of
them in the past three years have you
ever had doubts about whether or not you
should have removed a child from their
home
oh yeah there's definitely doubt am i
doing the right thing
you know who's who's who's gonna suffer
from this the most in 2017 alone an
estimated seventeen hundred and twenty
children died from abuse and neglect in
the u.s. more than a quarter of those
children were previously known to Child
Protective Services agencies the issue
came to light earlier this year with the
death of five-year-old age a friend in
Illinois investigators located what they
believe to be AJ's body buried in a
shallow grave wrapped in plastic police
charged his parents with murder child
welfare workers had been called to their
home before stories like that frustrate
Maine State Senator Bill Diamond who's
been focused on this issue for nearly
two decades we're not making progress
the former teacher has introduced a bill
pushing for a long term commission to
study the problems within his state's
Child Protective Services Department
kids are being abused right now while
you and I are talking they're being
abused terribly the only reason we don't
know who they are is because they
haven't died yet
experts say caseworkers in many areas
are underpaid and overworked reports of
abuse have increased more than 12
percent since 2013 partly because of
tougher laws requiring the reporting of
suspected abuse along with an increase
in calls related to the opioid epidemic
this mother says her addiction began
with a prescription for painkillers
after oral surgery 15 years ago I've
never been homeless I would hate to
become homeless but there are worse
things not being with my children would
be one of them things have you ever had
your children taken from you yes he ran
out of gamee County the number of kids
in foster care has doubled over the past
four years but Brittany Plowman says she
believes that children and this
household are safe
for now with their father at home and
with the additional assistance the
county is providing do you think this
issue doesn't get enough attention more
often than not it's the bad stuff that
services and not the good and I feel
like that needs more attention because
there's a lot of good that comes from
child welfare it's not just about
removals the bottom line here is Child
Protective Services workers say it's
heart-wrenching to take kids away from
their parents and try to avoid it unless
it's necessary they say they can reduce
the risk but can't entirely eliminate
the possibility that parents or
caregivers will make tragic decisions
after they leave so you know this this
hits close to home I think cuz I have a
lot of social workers and my family and
you forget just how difficult this work
is and keep doing it it does you know
they're overworked underpaid there has
to be an emotional toll absolutely and
these people are staying especially in
Outagamie County about three years on
average but the manager there who
oversees this department says that it
takes about two years just to train them
yeah so as soon as you train the people
that are ready they leave they arrive
they get burned out yeah it's that very
very difficult but what I wanted to say
too is the manager of that department
which I loved she said that this is not
just hard work it's heart work yeah yeah
and there's more of that interview that
you can find on our website CBS this
morning I would think of times it's
heartbreaking
we're so ruling what's so important
Jericka thank you very much